today's show is sponsored by vincero
watches which is an american company
building
super premium wrist watches starting at
only about a hundred and fifty dollars
and they're giving you 15 off when you
go to davidpakman.com
vincero i've put the link underneath
this video today's show
also sponsored by blinkist which is the
app that lets you read or listen to
an entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blinkist totally
free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman that link is underneath the
video as well
ladies and gentlemen we got him one of
the biggest
stories for sure of the last three
months
if not the last three years the new york
times
has obtained donald trump's tax return
data extending over more than two
decades the contents of the tax
information
is absolutely stunning is it devastating
to trump
i don't know i don't know that his
followers care about
anything at this point we will talk
about that but
this is much of but not all much of
what many have been waiting for for
years
donald trump's tax returns which he said
in 2015
once he's no longer under audit he would
release whatever happened to that
we know that he was just lying well they
are now out some of the revelations
include donald trump paid a total
of 750 in federal income taxes the year
that he won the presidency
750 dollars total
in his first year in the white house his
total
federal tax payments were 750
dollars he paid no federal
income taxes at all in 10 of the
previous 15 years
none how much did you pay how much did i
pay
if i showed you the amount of federal
tax i
paid and the amount trump paid you would
assume
i made way more money than donald trump
in these years
uh this entire decade-long
audit battle with the internal revenue
service
has been exposed as being over the
legitimacy
of a nearly 73 million dollar
tax refund that donald trump claimed
understand that
donald trump filed taxes claiming he was
entitled
to 72.9 million dollars of a tax refund
he received that tax refund and that is
now
in being investigated donald trump may
have stolen
73 million dollars from you for me
from whoever else actually paid taxes
and if indeed
that was an inappropriate refund that he
claimed he may be on the hook for 100
million dollars once you account for the
fees and fines
um on top of all of this the documents
do confirm that donald trump has been
overstating
his business strength in 2018
as an example donald trump disclosed in
a financial disclosure which is not a
legal document
that he made 430 million dollars
the tax records say he lost 47 million
dollars now
of course if you want to seem rich but
save on taxes
you would disclose a lot of money
and you would argue for tax purposes you
lost money this is a gap of more than
500 million dollars
and it is connected to all of these
other very clear instances
of donald trump claiming that people
need to pay they pay their fair share
donald trump's tweets about half of
americans pay no federal tax
because they don't produce anything
trump's the one barely paying federal
taxes
every single thing we thought trump
might be hiding
he's hiding we said you know trump might
be hiding that he's paying very little
in taxes despite being a super rich dude
that is exactly right we said you know
trump might be hiding that
his businesses aren't really doing so
well he's not as wealthy as he wants
people to think
and that is exactly right we said he
might
owe people a ton of money making him a
good target
and that is exactly right the documents
that the new york times has obtained
show that donald trump has 300 million
dollars
in loans which he is personally
responsible for
they come due in the next few years if
trump is re-elected we will have a
president
who uh owes 300 million dollars and has
to start paying it back during his
second term and
in total 421 million dollars in debt
is donald trump to whom does he owe that
money
that's a real question that's always by
the way josh campbell former
fbi agent said when you vet people
for federal government jobs if they have
a lot of debt
that is a red flag because it makes them
potentially
um vulnerable to being pressured
because of those debts that they have
look at what donald trump owes
and then as always with donald trump
there's a tweet for everything
donald trump tweeting in 2012 that quote
barack obama
who wants to raise all our taxes only
pays 20.5 percent
on a 790 000 salary do as i say
not as i do pays 20 trump paid
zero dollars in 10 of the last 15 years
now the important question in the end
because we're 40 days from an election
we are
five weeks from an election the question
in the end is does this make a
difference
will this influence voters i don't know
that it will
this obviously runs completely counter
to what donald trump ran on donald trump
ran on him for the middle class
donald trump ran on i'm from personal
responsibility we have too many people
who pay no taxes blah blah blah blah
blah
remember that during the 2016 election
when the narrative was
it takes someone to know how to play the
game in order to fix it for everybody
that's what trump ran on
okay yeah listen maybe i know how to
play the game so i'm going to fix it
didn't quite pan out did it
who would have thought that a giant
beneficiary of the system might want to
maintain it
obviously as we've been saying and yet
so many people are worse off
economically
now than they were when donald trump
took office
and trump's the one paying 750 in
federal taxes
the people who will be appalled by this
though
they're already not voting for donald
trump i was already getting tweets
yesterday from people saying dude
this is why trump's so smart he hasn't
paid taxes in years
legally or hey listen trump's business
has lost
money some years so those years he
shouldn't be paying taxes and what's
hilariously hypocritical about these
overlapping rebuttals is that you've got
the same people who are saying hey
listen if trump's business has lost
money
he shouldn't be paying taxes those are
the same people who say trump's a
business genius well
hold on a second which one is it which
one is it
so in the end i don't know if this is
going to move the needle
it only needs to move the needle a
little bit if we can get if this story
gets a few people to vote who weren't
going to
it could be so close in some key states
that it might actually make a difference
in the end
now on the back end of this story
there is an even bigger story there's a
systemic story here
which is much bigger than trump and i
think that for the next 40 days the
story is
trump and his taxes in 41 days assuming
joe biden wins
the story here is we have a tax system
set up to help the really wealthy avoid
paying taxes
in mostly legal ways although again
donald trump may have taken a 73 million
refund that he didn't actually deserve
so this is about donald trump
but it's also about systemic abuse it's
about
how warren buffett has famously pointed
out that there are years
where his effective tax rate was lower
than his secretaries if i recall
correctly i'm going from memory
uh warren buffett a turbo billionaire
warren buffett
once said that there was a year where
his effective tax rate was like 17
and his secretaries was 21
that's really the big story here beyond
donald trump
we're going to have plenty of time to
deal with that story
but for the next 40 days does this hurt
trump let me know what you think
we also have dystopian news not just
from the world of donald trump's taxes
but from the world of the supreme court
because donald trump has indeed
nominated the supreme
court to the supreme court the seventh
circuit judge
who we reported to you last week as the
front-runner
her name is amy coney barrett i have
clips
from this completely authoritarian
nightmare event during which donald
trump
nominated amy coney barrett but i do
want to remind you of a few things
before we get to that
last week in my segment about amy coney
barrett
i told you that she is not merely a
federalist society type
she's not merely an anti-abortion type
she's not merely a
it's all for god even the legal system
type
i told you that she's part of a cult
called the people of praise
which is reminiscent of the cult that
margaret atwood describes in the
dystopian novel a handmaid's tale
and i got a few emails over the weekend
from people saying you know david you
have to apologize
apologize because people of praise
was not actually the inspiration for
handmaid's tale
that was fake news and you fell for it
so let me clarify now no no
no i didn't fall for anything i was very
much aware
last week that handmaid's tale was
inspired by a different
group called people of hope i never said
last week
that people of praise was the
inspiration for handmaid's tale
i told you that there are some
interesting overlaps
barrett is part of people of praise and
there are
reminiscent elements of people of praise
that we see in handmaid's tale for
example
people of praise previously referred to
women in the cult
as handmaids now they've since changed
the name a people of praise believes in
the subjugation
of women in households as a matter of
default
that's reminiscent of a handmaid's tale
yes people of praise was not
what inspired margaret atwood's book but
i never said
that people of praise was what inspired
margaret atwood's book so please stop
asking me for apologies that don't make
any sense
now on to the event donald trump
announced that yes
amy coney barrett is his nominee to
replace ruth bader ginsburg
putting in place a possible justice
who would close many of the doors that
ruth bader ginsburg
opened and left opened behind her it's
tragic
it's nothing short of tragic so let's
get into it donald trump here
reading from a teleprompter the same
type of teleprompter he slams joe biden
for using making it official amy coney
barrett
is his nominee to replace rbg
today it is my honor to nominate one of
our nation's most brilliant
and gifted legal minds to the supreme
court
she is a woman of unparalleled
achievement
towering intellect sterling credentials
and unyielding loyalty to the
constitution
judge amy coney barrett
so this really is horrible this is the
exact
opposite of the type of person we should
have on the court you look at other
countries
and you see other countries moving
forward we're moving backwards we're
putting in more people
who are against abortion people who
believe that civil government
is a system meant to serve religious
interests sami coney barrett
uh saying that reportedly when she spoke
to notre dame
at notre dame this could not be more
dystopian and toxic
and the entire event was whacked donald
trump here without
even a semblance of irony and no iota of
ironing
irony urges lawmakers to refrain
from personal attacks
[Music]
i further urge all members of the other
side of the aisle to provide judge
barrett with the respectful and
dignified hearing
that she deserves and frankly that our
country deserves
i urge lawmakers and members of the
media to refrain from personal or
partisan attacks and the stakes for our
country
are incredibly high yeah donald trump
who's been saying sleepy joe biden has
dementia and trook
took drugs before his debate with bernie
and the same donald trump that attacked
meghan markle last week
that donald trump is saying don't make
personal attacks
against amy coney barrett here is
barrett
confirming that she is in line with the
ideology of
the late right-wing supreme court
justice
antonin scalia absolutely horrifying
and given his incalculable influence on
my life i am very moved to have members
of the scalia family here today
including his dear wife maureen
i clerked for justice scalia more than
20 years ago
but the lessons i learned still resonate
his judicial philosophy is mine too
so as i said last week i do not believe
that at this point we have any way to
stop this
but we still do have things we can stop
like another four years of donald trump
this ship may have sailed
if the republicans want to it's become
clear
because there are only two republicans
that said they would not
vote to confirm a supreme court justice
at this time
if they have the votes they've they've
had the votes now we'll see how the
confirmation hearings go you still do
the confirmation hearings for a reason
but what we can stop is trump getting
more supreme court justices uh clarence
thomas
is uh not a spring chicken at this point
it is likely that
one maybe two supreme court justices
would be replaced
during the next presidential term i
don't want donald trump getting those
selections
i don't know if you do but from what
we're seeing so far i don't think
anybody should
let me know your thoughts let me know
what you think the strategy should be
from here
through the election i'm on twitter at d
pacman
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy
science they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
all right so joe biden did an event
yesterday where he spoke
about donald trump's nomination of amy
coney barrett to the supreme court to
replace ruth bader ginsburg we already
looked at clips from
the nomination ceremony on saturday that
donald trump held at the white house and
at this event joe biden
also took questions from the media now
as all of you know
i don't agree with joe biden on every
policy or nearly every policy but in
some places i think joe biden has put
together some pretty reasonable
platforms which i would love to see
made a reality if he becomes president
but joe biden yesterday did something
really well
which is that he'd refused to play
donald trump's games and he refused to
play some of the games
that the media gets donald trump to play
but joe biden wasn't going to go for it
because joe biden was asked
in light of trump's supreme court
nominee
and the nomination being so hypocritical
given that republicans
in 2016 said oh we don't confirm
justices in the last year of a term
and now with 40 days to go they want to
confirm a supreme court justice
in light of that hypocrisy a question
that has come up
is whether joe biden will try to pack
the supreme court if he wins
should democrats try to pack the supreme
court
now packing the supreme court is
essentially expanding the court you add
justices so
if donald trump gets amy coney barrett
confirmed you would have a supreme court
that leans
six to three in the direction of
conservatives
joe biden could add four seats to the
supreme court
that would make it a 13 justice court
instead of nine
and he could appoint left-wing justices
to those four new seats
taking control of the court back making
it a 7-6
liberal majority now of course this is
hugely controversial
it's a major issue it is a non-starter
if joe biden doesn't win and
it doesn't happen in conjunction with
democrats taking the senate
but the great thing joe biden does
is he realizes that whether he says yes
or no
it's trouble and he's not going to play
the game with the reporter and he keeps
the focus on the now
take a look at how joe biden handled
this
he's almost no i have no comment
yes
that
expanding is court as president under
any circumstances whatsoever i am not
and i i i know you're going to be upset
with my answer
but what i'm not going to do is play the
trump game which is a good game he plays
take your eye off the issue before us
if i were to say yes or no to that that
becomes a big issue
that's the headline here i am focused on
one thing right now and i really mean it
i'm focused on
making sure the american people
understand
that they're being cut out of this
process they're entitled to be part of
and the cutout designed in order
to take away the aca and your health
care
in the midst of a pandemic that's the
focus
that's what it's on and that's the deal
thank you all so very very much
thank you so tomorrow we're going to
look at a clip of dr
jill biden handling a sort of bogus
direction during a cnn interview but joe
biden doing the right thing here
joe biden is correctly identifying that
you can't win
with that question if joe biden says yes
i will consider packing the court or i
will definitely try to pack the court
the right goes crazy and calls biden an
authoritarian and a fascist and all the
things that donald trump actually wants
to be
if joe biden says yes i will pack the
court
those on the left who think it's a bad
idea
that it's a divisive idea they will get
mad at joe biden
and then if joe biden says no i won't
consider packing the court
those on the left who want him to pack
the court will say this is why the dems
lose
they're weak they give in they won't
ever do what they need to do so joe
biden correctly points out
right now donald trump is trying to get
amy coney barrett confirmed
she wants to get rid of the affordable
care act she's very much against roe v
wade period that's the issue right now
and this is something that i i guess
we've become kind of
descensible or not decent we've we've i
am re-sensitized
to when an elected official properly
handles
a bad question or a poorly framed
question because
with the trump administration it's
either
trump's asked a question and he just
talks about something totally different
or trump is asked a question and he lies
but this is actually how you handle some
of these questions that have no possible
upside now earlier in the event joe
biden also made it very clear and i
think that this goes to
to to something that's astute that biden
and his campaign are doing right now
joe biden makes clear that what donald
trump is doing on the supreme court
is outrageous and that at the core of it
is wanting to dismantle
a lot of this policy including the
affordable care act take a look
shortly before justice ginberg's passed
she uh she told her granddaughter and i
quote
my most fervent wish is that i will not
be replaced until a new president
is installed and a quote it wasn't a
personal request
it wasn't a favor being asked for
it was the last act of a long
unflinching career of standing
up for american democracy
never before in our nation's history has
the supreme court justice been nominated
and installed while a presidential
election
is already underway it defies
every precedent every expectation
of a nation where the people the people
are sovereign
and the rule of law reigns
but yesterday before justice ginsburg
could be laid to rest and after a
hundred thousands of americans
had already cast their ballots the
president nominated
a successor to her seat it's no mystery
about what's happening here
president trump was trying to throw out
the affordable care act
he's been trying to do it for the last
four years
the republican party has been trying to
eliminate it
for a decade so i don't agree with biden
all the time on policy i certainly don't
agree with biden all the time on
strategy but i think that this is
logical keep the pressure on what they
are trying to do right now
rather than the hypotheticals if joe
biden wins there's
more than enough time for those
hypotheticals and when the hypotheticals
might ingratiate you with some but
alienate others there's very little
upside to going in that direction what
joe biden is trying to do here
is to cement in the minds of the voters
the stakes that are at play
and that hopefully i'm hoping he will do
that tomorrow night during the first
presidential debate tomorrow
tuesday we will be starting live
coverage of the first
presidential debate between donald trump
and joseph r
biden jr 8 30 p.m eastern time
5 30 p.m pacific we will be live on
youtube
live on twitch and live on facebook i
hope you will join me
this is precisely the correct messaging
from joe biden and
by the way as a now we're getting into
just real
nitty gritty policy i still don't
understand how repealing or gutting the
affordable care act
without a real replacement plan which
trump doesn't have
days before an election i don't even get
how that's a winning strategy for
donald trump that's another story
altogether but they
are again talking about how quickly can
we get rid of the affordable care act
days before an election with no plan to
replace it
you're going to try to get rid of it i
don't see how that's winning electoral
strategy
but donald trump did win in 2016 so
maybe he knows something i don't
last wednesday was a very important
uh a day because we had an article
published in the atlantic
about donald trump's plan to steal this
election should he lose to joe biden
we talked about it the plan is to use
allegations of fraud
to justify trump choosing republican
electors
even in states where joe biden won by
saying well joe biden didn't really win
because of fraud
so i'm going to send republican electors
or ask
the state legislature to send republican
electors
this would be done in conjunction with
the use of lawyers to stop the counting
of absentee ballots on election day
this is a major story this is a story of
a desperate
sitting president with a very specific
plan to subvert the will of the people
to destroy democracy
you would think that that would be 24 7
coverage because it is a red alert
disaster
and yet the new york times put a story
about it
on page 15 of the newspaper that day the
washington post put it
closer to the front but many pages back
from the front page
cable channels gave it some coverage fox
news barely
but not really anything commensurate or
properly proportional
given the scope and magnitude of the
story a president not just with the
vague idea of trying to stay in power if
he loses
but a specific plan that he and
strategists and and republican attorneys
are discussing
and it didn't get that much coverage and
then on top of this
after the article came out brian karam
asked donald trump at a press briefing
will you commit to a peaceful transition
of power if you lose
and donald trump said well it depends on
the results remember this clip from last
week
when loser draw in this election will
you commit here today
for a peaceful trans referral of power
after the election
and there has been rioting in louisville
there's been rioting in many cities
across this country
red and your so-called red and blue
states will you commit to making sure
that there is a peaceful transferal of
power
after the election well we're gonna have
to see what happens you know that i've
been complaining very strongly about
the ballots and the ballots are a
disaster and
but people are rioting do you commit to
making sure that there's a peaceful
transfer
we want to get rid of the ballots and
you'll have a very trance we'll have a
very peaceful
there won't be a transfer frankly
there'll be a continuation
the ballots are out of control you know
it and you know who knows it better than
anybody else the democrats know it
better than anybody else go ahead
you know for all of the talk about how
the media
are so liberal and so anti-trump and
blah blah blah
the coverage of this story was lacking
the only
reasonable answer to will you commit to
a peaceful transition of power if you
lose
is of course i will yes so there's a
real question here
why did so many editors who decide what
gets on tv as i lose my sharpie
what gets published where in newspapers
why did they bury the story
dan frumkin from salon has one idea
and the idea is that news editors
couldn't possibly report this story
without having to sound a major alarm
and that very often
editors don't want to sound major alarms
because they are afraid of appearing
partisan and taking heat
and that this story is so outrageous
that you can't really touch it
without making it clear that this is
about does our democracy hold
so that that's why they didn't run the
story or didn't run it prominently or
didn't talk about it much
i actually think there's a much more
dangerous and disturbing explanation
for why this story did not get the
coverage it deserved
and it's that trump's base doesn't care
about it they don't have a problem
with donald trump saying this when 30 to
40 percent of the country
would accept a stolen election as long
as it's their guy who stole it
is it really a big story if half the
country wouldn't be outraged
that is the real tragedy they keep being
told
democrats are stealing and committing
fraud and all this stuff
for four years they've been doing it and
the news is fake
how do you even get them to care about a
president saying
yeah i might steal the election or try
to anyway
this is the end point conclusion
of the i can shoot people on fifth
avenue and not lose support mentality
the bet has been made and now
how do we get people to stop sleeping in
it it is
very dark times potentially that are
coming here we're going to have more
coverage of this
on our instagram page david pakman show
on instagram and if you want something
light
because things are pretty dark if you
want a video of me chasing puppies
around
actually i guess the puppies are chasing
me around it's not clear there's a lot
of running
follow me on instagram at david.pacman
we'll be back after this
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
one of our sponsors today is vincero
watches
and they're giving you 15 off everything
in the store
if you're a guy looking for the perfect
way to refresh your style one of the
best investments you can make is in a
high quality
wrist watch vincero is an american
company
that has made it possible for everyday
people to afford
a premium watch almost everything they
sell is within the range of about 200
but it'll look like you spent a lot more
all of their watches are made in small
batches from
top quality materials and they just look
great
i went on their site and picked out a
watch from their icon automatic
collection the one i got
is in mesh matte black and i love it
it's simple sleek elegant
goes great with just about anything i'm
wearing and i've gotten a ton of
compliments on it
you'll get 15 off everything in their
store
when you go to davidpakman.com slash
vincero
i've put the link right underneath this
video
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
so after nominating amy coney barrett to
replace ruth bader ginsburg on the
supreme court donald trump had another
one of these rallies and you can tell
he's emboldened he's feeling powerful
he's feeling the alpha male
although remember that we can still hold
him
accountable for his perversion of
democracy and remove him
let's look at a few clips from this
event this was a rally in middletown
pennsylvania
it was truly horrifying yes donald trump
was
again struggling to speak of course
we'll get those out of the way
first saying joe biden should be asking
people not for forgiveness
but for forgiveness
all right take a listen to this you
shouldn't be asking
for your vote he should be begging for
your forgiveness
a little hokey he'll help people
yeah that's not really the dystopian
part it got
truly dystopian and authoritarian very
very quickly donald trump here
commending u.s marshals for killing a
man
who was suspected of murder in portland
one eyewitness says that the man was
executed by u.s marshals note that this
doesn't include this thing what's that
thing called the write always talks
about it
uh oh due process i'm sorry yeah due
process uh it doesn't include due
process take a look
portland is anarchist and you had the
guy two weeks ago remember he shot and
killed the young man in the middle of
the street just shot him like
oh i don't even say like what because
his parents
are so devastated a young man and they
shot him and killed him this one guy
this one animal
and two and a half that's right over his
hat
not our hat it was another hat it was a
christian hat it was a christian hat
he was a christian he was a christian
and they shot him
killed him instantly and this guy that
shot him everybody knew who he was
right and i said after two days where is
he did you arrest him no he didn't
after two and a half days did you arrest
him and then i put out on
social media why didn't you arrest him
and you know what
the u.s marshal saw it they went in
and he pulled a gun on him and 15
minutes it was all over
none of our guys were hurt and he was
gay
these crowds will cheer for anything
they
they truly will then trump continuing
with his fear-mongering about the
election
thanks to mail-in ballots which trump is
simultaneously saying
will be fraudulent but at the state
level the trump campaign is telling
people
their supporters request absentee
ballots vote by mail vote by mail
notice in this one that donald trump's
fear-mongering starts to peter out like
he almost
it looks like he's running out of
batteries and he seems to realize he's
not making much sense
so he goes back to the teleprompter
which he uses despite
attacking joe biden for using one it's
actually
jarring when trump switches from riffing
aimlessly
back to the prompter and all i'm asking
is people go out to vote
go out to vote and stop with this
nonsense because we're going to be
counting ballots for the next two years
and i don't want to end up in the
supreme court and i don't want to go
back to congress either
even though we have an advantage if we
go back to congress does everyone
understand that
i think it's 26 to 22 or something
because
it's counted one vote per state so we
actually have an
advantage oh they're going to be
thrilled to hear that
i'm sure they're trying to figure out
how can we break that one
biden wants to confiscate your guns and
indoctrinate your children
with poisonous anti-american lies in
schools right
donald trump does this unintentionally
hilarious thing during these speeches
where he reads the teleprompter not as
if they're his own words he reads the
teleprompter as if it's a news article
that he's commenting on
and then he'll react to it sometimes he
actually seems surprised by what's on
the teleprompter
very very odd particularly for a guy who
criticizes everybody else for using
teleprompters
then his fans start chanting lock her up
when hillary clinton's name was raised
and donald trump
says i agree lock her up
that was like hillary remember she made
a horrible statement
about clean coal and then she went
crooked hillary
and then she went three weeks later
i agree trump has now said
really everybody should be locked up
hillary should be locked up
obama and biden at one point he said 50
years in prison they should be serving
for their crimes against trump trump
still has
not enumerated what those crimes are but
for their crimes against trump i believe
james comey should be locked up it
actually sounds like
a dictator when you say anybody who
disagrees with you politically should be
locked up
trump then still having trouble with the
size of his
crowds trump claims there were 35
000 people at his rally the previous
night in virginia
there were there were reportedly 4 000
people there take a look
if tens of thousands somebody said 17 18
000
last night we had 35 000 people you saw
that in virginia you know we're making a
play for virginia
because we have a governor in virginia
you know that facts simply do not matter
the facts don't matter about the micro
the facts don't matter about the macro
it is a culture of lies it is a culture
that does not care
what reality is coronavirus he did great
we're doing great well that's a lie
crowd size at some pathetic rally you
shouldn't even be having he says 35
000. it was really 4 000. maybe then
trump
starts talking this is almost sad if
this
weren't the president it would almost
make you kind of feel pity
trump is talking about his nobel prizes
as if he won them as opposed to being
nominated for them
by bogus right-wing european politicians
take a look gotten seven
but the fake news never even put it on
and somebody had a show where they said
the amount of time devoted to donald
trump's
nobel peace prize two of them zero on
the network
zero then the amount of time devoted to
something else that was
negative for somebody in the republican
party like
infinite it is so disgraceful
they're so bad trump's two nobel peace
prizes what he has no nobel peace prizes
as you might know and then trump starts
to wrap up his speech
but he kind of gets sidetracked riffing
about how he has all of these weapons at
his disposal
the likes of which no country has seen
before and he again
seems to still think that a stealth
plane
is not just invisible to radar
he still seems to think it's invisible
to the naked eye
and he pulls out that sir routine that
we've come to know so well
we might and we will ensure peace
through strength you know we rebuilt our
military you saw it 2.5 trillion dollars
we have weapons the
i i mean just to talk about them the
likes of which no country has ever
seen before the power the strength the
the
uh incredible talent and engineering we
have webs
weapons the likes of which no country
has ever seen before we are so far
advanced over every other country
and hope to god we never have to use
them and when i got here we were a
depleted
tired military with great people but we
were exhausted we had old jet fighters
now we have brand new f-35s that are
stealth
i asked one of the pilots how good are
these planes compared to the enemy you
say well one difference is you can't see
our planes
i said let me ask you i don't know too
much about flying that helps doesn't he
said it really helps
so you can tell you can tell that yes
the rallies have always been whacked
they've always been gong shows but you
see
an emboldened trump on the basis
of having nominated a replacement for
ruth bader ginsburg
and the probably accurate assessment in
his defense
that he is likely to get her confirmed
we've got an uphill battle ahead of us
here my friends
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show
as well as commercial free audio and
video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpackman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so now after the nomination of amy coney
barrett to the supreme court and
literally as
the new york times story exposing donald
trump's taxes was breaking donald trump
held
a press briefing and this was a very
haphazardly
scheduled press briefing it was sunday
in fact donald trump was golfing when
the press briefing was scheduled just a
few hours before
and although we don't know because they
don't tell us it's reasonable to
speculate that a last-minute press
briefing scheduled on a sunday
while donald trump is golfing may well
be to try to generate news and take
attention away from the breaking story
in the new york times
uh also completely plausible that the
trump administration knew it was going
to be published at least a few hours
before it was published so
needless to say donald trump holds a
press briefing
and it's completely pathetic it's
gaslighting it's delusional
it's perverse let's look at some of it
let's look at how dangerous this
is donald trump still it's like he's
taking attention away from the tax story
by saying horrible authoritarian things
trump still won't commit to voluntarily
leaving office if he loses
we all believe in transition but not
when the system is rigged he says now i
do apologize for the
bad audio quality of these clips
something was wrong with the audio
in the transmission it's it's not on our
end but let's take a look at this first
one
and it's uh very dangerous for our
country so
certainly transition we all believe in
transition we believe
not only in transition but very friendly
but when the ballots and when the system
is rigged
which it is obviously it is and
the only one that knows that better than
me are the democrats
and they go into closed rooms and they
must laugh like hell
at what's going on because these ballots
are being found and this is the
beginning
i talk about it now at the rallies all
these people are watching
eyes and ears thousands and thousands
tens of thousands
but there's no justification for these
extreme changes to the election law he
says
when it's rigged and that it's rigged
this time well then it's a different
situation
you don't just commit to a peaceful
transition when it's rigged then he says
it is indeed rigged
remember there are no extreme changes to
election law the way he says
all we've done is expand the list of
valid reasons for voting absentee in
some states sending people an absentee
ballot application
which they can fill out and send back if
they want an absentee ballot has been
expanded
but there have been no radical or
extreme changes
so then the questions actually start
about the new york times tax story
and trump first just sort of weirdly
denies it all
but doesn't make any sense completely
collapsing under just basic questioning
frankly everybody's going to talk about
there's a new york times story that came
out about an hour ago
that says that when you came to the
white house you were paying about 750
a year in federal income tax they are
not releasing they're not publishing the
tax
returns they're not showing that out
there they're saying to
protect their sources in your tax return
sir does that sound right if you're
paying a couple hundred dollars a year
with no income taxes
it's fake news it's totally fake news
made up
fake we went through the same stories
you could ask me the same questions four
years ago i had to litigate this and
talk about it
uh totally fake news now actually i paid
tax but and you'll see that as soon as
my tax returns
it's under order they've been underwater
for a long time
the irs does not treat me well they
treat me like the tea party like they
treated the tea party
they don't treat me well they treat me
very badly
you have people that in the irs they
treat me very very badly
uh but they're under audit so trump is
asked about his taxes
and he simply says it's fake now i do
think
that eventually the new york times might
have to figure out how do you release
the actual documents
while protecting the identity of their
source so trump can't keep calling it
fake news
for now the new york times has reported
on the contents of the tax documents but
they've said
we can't release the documents because
it would potentially expose our source
and for now trump can say it's just fake
at some point
if the new york times can figure out how
to release the docs
without endangering or exposing their
source that would be a good
thing then trump is asked again about
the taxes and
listen to how pathetically weak his
pushback is
about the tax returns story though you
have to understand that
when americans read that you may have
paid only a few hundred dollars in
federal income tax per year
that seems very low for someone who's a
billionaire
so how much i mean basically they're
saying i paid nothing can you give
people an idea of how much you actually
are paying
yeah basically well first of all i paid
a lot and i paid a lot of state income
taxes too
uh the new york state charges a lot and
i paid a lot of money at state
uh it'll all be revealed it's going to
come out
but after the auditors after the how
much are you really paying
he says oh i'm paying a lot and you know
i pay state taxes
as well how interesting that now
trump has gone back to this talking
point of oh when my audits are done
we're going to release
the information which was what he said
in 2015 that's what he said in 2016 and
then of course
just stopped saying once he became
president of the united states
this story now it's not forcing him to
actually disclose anything
but it has pushed him to again go back
to well
once my audits are done we're going to
disclose everything it's just complete
gaslighting and anybody who's falling
for it at this point
what planet have you been living on for
the last four years donald trump
then was asked about does he really
think
that joe biden is using drugs to better
perform during debates we'll talk about
that a little bit later
and trump says yeah i'm not joking which
we should know trump doesn't tell
jokes you said this numerous times do
you really believe
that joe biden will be on any type of
performance enhancing drug ahead of the
debates
or are you just joking no not joking i
mean
i'm willing to take a drug test i think
he should too because he's had a very
uneven i watched him with uh some of the
when he was with you know debating uh
pocahontas and
uh harris who treated him so badly but i
watched him
and he was out of it right and then i
watched him against
bernie sanders that he was okay i mean
he wasn't great
but he wasn't terrible he was okay
a far cry from the way he you know what
i'm saying i mean if you look at some of
those debates
i said there's no way he can continue he
can't continue
then all of a sudden he debated crazy
bernie sanders and you know what the
truth is he was
he was okay this is a president talking
this way
no other country at our level of
development or even below it would allow
this and yet it's daily here in the
united states
and trump continuing to push this asked
for sources on joe biden
juicing says oh just look at the
internet a president asked for facts
says
look at the internet okay and i said how
did he go
from there with those horrible
performances
to where he was okay and i always joke
but you know it is true he was no
winston churchill
in debating but he was fine and
people say he was on performance
enhancing drugs a lot of people have
said that a lot of people have written
that
so let's take a look at it take a look
why don't you just check it and you can
check out the internet you'll see plenty
of people
say it now finally trump is saying
something true
which is that you can find people on the
internet
saying biden use drugs you can find
people on the internet
saying the earth is flat you can find
people on the internet saying obama is a
reptilian not of this earth
trump is finally right about something
you can find just about any nonsense you
want on the internet
and then trump continuing to lie about
his crowd size
again suggesting there were 30 or 35 000
people at a recent rally there were 4
000 people there remember
you know that i don't know if it would
have been reported before but all of
these rallies those you know we had
thousands of people last night as you
know
and we're in harrisburg pennsylvania uh
the night before we were in virginia
i mean those crowds are whether it was
35
000 or 30 those crowds are massive
and that's on very short notice all of
those people are watching
you know we have eyes and ears now that
we wouldn't have had if we didn't bring
it up
so no i'm sure she's watching and i'm
sure that everybody's looking at it i
think
i think it's just common sense go ahead
it's just lie about the big stuff
lie about the small stuff lie all the
time and then one more thing
this every every time this happens it's
it's just a reminder
that presidents sometimes can talk about
policy
trump can't trump was asked about the
conflict
between armenia and azerbaijan and he
can do nothing other than to say
we're looking at it very strongly it's
it's a meme now but that's actually what
he said
mr president thank you mr president
you know that could you we have a little
lesson
thank you and there has been uh
going on the military action in the
carnival azerbaijan
and where the azerbaijan yeah the karma
and the civilians
are killed and according to the
officials from the azerbaijan they
say the first fruit came from the
armenian what's your comment on that so
we're looking at it very strongly just
happened and
i know about it i learned about it today
and
yesterday and we're looking at it very
strongly
we have a lot of good relationships in
that area we'll see if we can stop it
okay thank you very much everybody in 10
of the
previous 15 years before the 2016
elections you played
unable to speak in depth about
any issue so this is now
maybe the story through the election or
maybe not is this the october surprise
the trump tax story
that came a few days early or is
something even crazier going to break
between now and the election
i don't even i don't even have any
interest nor ability to guess anything
could happen
okay let's talk a little bit about the
drug test thing because i think that
there is actually a story here
donald trump continues to request that
he and joe biden be drug tested either
before or after the upcoming
presidential debate the debate is
tomorrow i hope you'll watch it with me
live on youtube twitter facebook
and there's a piece of this story that
is distraction
and there's a piece of the story that is
projection so let's talk about each
donald trump for a while has been saying
joe biden's performance against bernie
sanders during that debate it was too
good
biden must have been on something
recently saying that joe biden got a
shot of something remember this clip
from last week
the gloves off this guy doesn't have a
clue he doesn't know where the hell he
is
and they'll give him a shot of something
i don't know he's going to get something
he'll be
you know because i watched him so badly
he performed so badly in the debates and
then
with bernie he was average not great but
he got through
and i said what the hell is he taking
and we'd like to ask him and i said that
we want a drug test we want a drug test
we'll both take it
there's the the idea again and yesterday
donald trump
again brings this up by tweeting quote i
will be
strongly demanding a drug test of sleepy
joe biden
prior to or after the debate on tuesday
night
naturally i will agree to take one also
his debate performances have been record
setting
uneven to put it mildly only drugs could
have caused this discrepancy
i continue to get the sense that there
is projection here
trump talking so much about performing
better in public speaking events
because of drugs because of being on
something and meanwhile the speculation
has been raging for years that it's
trump who is on something and in reality
it is as specific as trump says in the
tweets but about himself
it's trump's public speaking
performances that are
so uneven that it raises questions we've
casually called it
upper trump versus downer trump or
adderall trump versus benzo trump but
the point is
what trump points out in biden these
uneven performances
that's exactly what has raised the alarm
about donald trump trump sometimes very
sweaty with dilated pupils even in front
of bright lights
talking quickly verbal glitches the
shoulder and the
the elbow spasms that we've noticed
other times it's a different person it's
a different guy
it's a slowed down trump seems sad and
low energy
almost an ambulant like he's sleep
talking sleepwalking
so that's the projection piece that
trump seems to be pointing out in biden
what we observe
in trump the distraction piece is that
even if trump is on drugs
trump must know that there is not going
to be an actual drug test
before the debate or after the debate so
he can tweet about it and talk about it
with no actual risk
that he will be drug tested and that is
what is meant as distraction it's a
distraction from you know pick your
poison coronavirus
the tax story his attempts to rig the
election in his favor
whatever and by the way in the meantime
we are about 24 hours 30 hours as of
right now from the first debate
does anybody in my audience think either
candidate will back out
because from day one you've had trump
and friends saying
joe biden's going to find a way out so
that he doesn't have to do it
and in the meantime you've had some on
the left saying trump's going to be the
one who finds a way out maybe it'll be
bone spurs or you know whatever
at this late stage just a day before the
first debate
if you think either candidate will back
out for this reason or that reason or
for whatever reason that the debate
isn't going to happen i would love to
hear from you now just one last thought
on this
is it possible that donald trump is
raising the drug test issue
so that when the commission on
presidential debates
doesn't require drug tests which they
obviously will not
trump can say i'm not doing it if we're
not drug testing i'm not doing it
because i think joe biden is on
something a few people emailed me that
idea over the weekend
i'm running it by you to see what you
think right now
i believe the debate happens but what on
earth do i know but i do think at least
the first debate happens maybe if it
goes horribly wrong
for one or the other candidate maybe
they'll try to figure out a way
not to have the second and third debates
but i believe tomorrow's debate happens
if you disagree with me let me know we
have a voicemail number which you can
call anytime that number is
219 to david p here is a good question
but from someone who sounds maybe a
little confused about the numbers take a
listen to this
hey i um my name is billy i call from
middle of new jersey
i had a thought about the election if
you
think about all the info and everybody
who's voting
what's the best possible voter number
count going into this election i'm
thinking
for joe biden to win no matter what it's
got to be 120 million votes
and that would probably leave donald
trump to 40 to 50
mil that's my thought on him
best possible chance of winning no
matter what okay so listen you you are
correctly identifying that joe biden
needs a big margin of victory in the
popular vote to
safely if you account for everything if
you account for
the way in which the system is lopsided
to help republicans that's the electoral
college system to account for
uh voter fraud that uh not
voter suppression rather and election
fraud
and all of those other things yes joe
biden needs a nice
healthy popular vote margin but 120
million to 40 million is not going to
happen that that's just not
first of all i don't even think that
that many people are going to vote
um last election it was both hillary and
trump had in the 60 million range i
don't remember if it was 63 to 60 or
64 to 62 something like that uh what
you're suggesting
120 million to 40 million that's like a
three to one victory for joe biden joe
biden's not gonna win 75 to 25
okay i think that if you look at the
data
and nate silver has put this data out if
joe biden can win by
four his chances of winning the
electoral college are
very very good if joe biden were to win
by five or six in the popular vote
he would almost certainly win the
electoral college so you're thinking
in the right terms the numbers are a
little bit out there
but the point is we need every vote
we need to run up the score in every
state
assume nothing concede nothing
and if we do that you could have joe
biden
in the high 60 millions and donald trump
in the low 60 millions it is certainly
possible
we have a great bonus show planned for
you today uh donald trump's former
campaign manager has been hospitalized
it's a very sad story actually
we're going to talk about it there is a
cult leader who claims to be the
reincarnation of jesus i've actually
seen
a documentary about him he's been
arrested in russia we'll tell you why
and also
major breaking news on time travel
although i guess if time travel were
possible
somebody would have already come back
and done the bonus show already and
you'd know by now
no i'm kidding but major news about
paradox
free time travel which i am very much
looking forward to discussing with you
on the bonus show get
instant access to the bonus show by
becoming a member at joinpakman.com
and don't forget tomorrow night 8 30 p.m
eastern
5 30 p.m pacific debate number one
between donald trump and joe biden
thanks so much for watching today's
episode just a reminder today's program
was made possible by vincero
watches the american watchmaker building
super quality wrist watches
but making them affordable for everyday
people and they're giving you 15
off when you go to davidpakman.com
vincero
today's show also sponsored by blinkist
blinkist is the app that lets you read
or listen to an entire nonfiction book
in 15 minutes and you can try blinkist
for free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put that link down
below
underneath the video